one one person said you're mr drug cop
himself the absolute best of the best
the fiercest leader and the true
definition of baltimore's finest he's
continuously trained young officers due
to having an abundant amount of
knowledge in the craft that he has
perfected you always feel safe and
comfortable with match even in a [ __ ]
up situation he will make you laugh and
he will ease your mind
[Music]
we're dropping the first two episodes of
the real ones and today we feature a
city that is right in the center of my
heart city of baltimore this episode
features one of baltimore's finest tony
maggio tony was raised in baltimore's
east side and he grew up to police those
same streets he's revered by everyone on
the force and he's also earned the
respect of the community that he polices
that's because not only does he take his
job seriously but he pleases with
respect and he pleases with compassion i
don't want to embarrass you but i just
thought we we got a couple quotes of
some some things that police have said
about you okay uh on the department um
i'm not gonna tell you who they're from
but i'm just i'm just gonna read a
couple of them one of them said that uh
you're honest you're kind you're up
front you're trustworthy
and you're the king of the east side
one person said that um you have a
calming effect actually a lot of people
said that that you have a calming effect
you always feel safe and comfortable
with match
even in a [ __ ] up situation he will
make you laugh and he will ease your
mind
one one person said you mr drug cop
himself the absolute best of the best
the fiercest leader and the true
definition of baltimore's finest he's
continuously trained young officers do
it due to having an abundant amount of
knowledge in the craft that he has
perfected so that's what that they're
saying about you so i guess like just to
start off man um tell me like where
you're from what part of the city you're
from and what the city of baltimore
means to you so grew up in baltimore um
was born on the east side i lived in a
loser in a monument
one thing from baltimore you'll find out
when you ask somebody where they're from
it's either going to be an intersection
or 100 block
or on east side west side something like
that we don't really give uh that's kind
of like how we relate to where we're
from okay um and it kind of stayed on
the east side my whole life for the most
part
um moved away a couple times you know
with family like to florida california
but always ended up back in baltimore
and then we didn't move out of the city
until
kind of when i was like 15 we moved down
to the suburbs um just because it was
getting really bad and i started getting
a little bit of trouble
but yeah i mean i grew up in a rough
part of the city you know and i watched
it change over the years you know as a
kid and you know i have older brothers
and i saw a lot of things you know
happen in the neighborhood and with my
own family that
you know um
just didn't
think i wanted to be a part of
you know and never really knew what i
wanted to do
um i just
knew that what i didn't want to do you
know and seeing some friends you know
get involved in things that
probably they shouldn't be getting
involved in you know growing up in
baltimore is a great city you know i
love this city i always have
when i decided i wanted to be a cop so
any place i wanted to come to be a cop
was baltimore growing up there and
just kind of seeing how the city was
failing you know as a whole
yeah when did you start seeing you saw
that at a young age a young age i mean i
had friends
you know drugs taking over the
neighborhoods and you know the crack
epidemic was terrible and the violence
you know just and when you have friends
that start getting involved in that now
i had friends in all different
areas of that city because i moved
around a lot and went to a bunch of
different schools throughout the city
like went to one school when i'm you
know
was expelled and then they sent me to
another would you get expelled for
fighting you know young kid you know you
think you're tough or whatever and
you know you get expelled you send you
to another school you meet another group
of friends and so i had friends that
were like really kind of soft kids
that would never get in trouble and then
my neighborhood friends you know were
rougher kids you know we lived in like a
rougher part what was that like that
part of east baltimore growing up what
was that like so young young it wasn't a
bad area you know when i was a little
kid you know five six seven it really
wasn't
crazy
violent at least in the neighborhood
baltimore like back then was different
there was more organization to it there
was more organization to the to the
crime game
years ago you know where even like on
sundays it was kind of like the old day
for criminals you know they didn't
really mess around they didn't mess with
the kids back then they didn't approach
us when we were young 10 11 12 year olds
trying to get us involved in anything
you know that's totally different these
days where they encourage the juvenile
to be involved yeah because of lots of
charges yeah but um i mean growing up in
baltimore there was crime you know like
had guns poured on me been shot at when
i was younger
but you don't really when you're growing
up in that type of environment you don't
realize it to be a bad environment sure
it's just your neighborhood sure you
know it's just things happen sure
because it's kind of how you view it you
know what i mean and
i've always you know got got in fights
things like that a little bit of
mischief never nothing were you know i
never got involved in drugs or dealing
with guns or anything like that because
it just wasn't my scene was there a
certain moment where you're like i'm
never going down that road
yeah my oldest brother he had some
problems you know um
with drugs back then drinking and he was
getting a lot of trouble and my dad was
involved in a lot of like you know he
was involved in drugs and things like
that and i hung out with my father one
time he used to have his green van his
nickname was turtle and he had this
green van and he was driving around and
like one time he picked me up and we
went collecting money i'm like
seven or eight years old but i'll never
forget it because i'm like naked hang on
my dad like you know you're a kid and
he's not in your life and the minute you
get to hang out with him you don't give
a [ __ ] what you're gonna do straight up
you know and he's like come on we're
gonna go do something i'm like all right
cool
so we're running around and we're
collecting money i don't know what for
and i'm young and dumb i really don't
know what's going on hey you're with
your dad man he gives a [ __ ] yeah right
and so we're going from spot to spot and
he's picking money up and this in his
van he had like a you know it's like
those old-school
um vans like a little window in the
corner in the back you know what i mean
and the carpeted floor and he rolls the
carpet up and he picks the floor up and
there's just a spot for money you know
i'll never forget it because it was like
for me i was oh my gosh it's like a
movie this is crazy yeah yeah he puts
the money in there rolls the carpet back
you know and i'm like we just keep doing
it you know what i mean and i was just
like man this is you know a wild
experience
and then
my mother my mother was always like stay
away from stay away from you know he's
like he's bad news and i'm like yeah
he's my dad like whatever
he had a club right down the street from
our house like a social club you know
like private you know always locked well
me and my buddy broke into one day
because they have pool tables now we
want to shoot pool yeah so i was like
eight years old we we broke into it and
uh
we're shooting pool and somebody hear
somebody playing with the locks oh [ __ ]
we gotta hide so we hid and the way we
got in was the deadbolt wasn't locked
the bottom lock wasn't we just pried
open with a butter knife and got in how
old are you eight
so we're in there shooting before we
hide
comes in
and the guy's doing whatever the guy's
doing and we're hiding and he leaves but
when he left he locked the deadpool but
it was a key on both sides there was no
knob so you couldn't unlock it to get
out yes now i'm stuck in this [ __ ]
club with my buddy and you know all the
windows are like blacked out there's
like bars on the front window there's
only a little window like this big on
the front window and then bars
so we're not banging on dwarf people
walking by trying to get someone's
attention
and then finally someone saw my ass in
the window and they went and got my mom
and man
they got my dad he came and let us out
and she was pissed yeah
you know and it was just her sitting me
down and kind of explaining to me like
who he was
you know and seeing
i mean she loved him but she hated him
and seeing the hatred she had for him
like how he made her feel
i just knew i never wanted to be like
him at that moment like you know at that
moment i knew like
i didn't know exactly what he was doing
but i knew whatever he was doing my
mother hated him
so much
that i never wanted to make her feel
like that wow you know well obviously
later on i found out like i knew what he
did and you know sold drugs and things
like that and anyone that you anyone
i've ever met and knew my father loved
him yeah as a person
said he was the greatest guy
his friends they all loved him
i never knew that side of him because he
didn't really care
about his family you know what i mean
well the the first time the first time
you and i met was over in the the
eastern division and when we started
talking you told me you're like i'm from
right over there
and you know east baltimore's east
baltimore man and and i remember you
said
you know it's it's different for you
because it's like these people it's like
you're from this neighborhood and you it
it it was just very clear for me i
remember like the first time that we
went and you know you guys got that gun
off that guy over in those those housing
projects and everyone was kind of like
approaching you treated every single
person with respect every single person
respected you like do you think that
that's where
you got this sort of empathy for the
community from because i mean obviously
it helps to be from the community but
the fact that you um look man it's
possible to be a criminal and still be a
a good human being and have love for
them yeah like my mega said my brother
was getting in trouble my oldest brother
and i saw the cops beat him up one time
you know you know he was i mean he
deserved it i mean i'll be the first to
tell you he was he was you know
high and acting crazy he could fight and
he was giving him the blues and more
showed up and they gave him no blues you
know and but i knew my brother i knew he
had a good heart and he was a good
person when he wasn't getting in trouble
and wasn't like
[ __ ] with drugs and you know drunk
and doing those things he was a great
person and i know and i knew how he
could be so i think i always kind of had
that mindset that just because someone's
doing something like i said there's
there's things you can forgive and
there's things you can't you know
someone you know
selling drugs or you know getting in a
fight or
things like that like you know these are
all things that you can forget like
there's still people that are just
making bad choices and if you you start
getting into like you know when you're
molesting kids and raping women and
killing people these are a little more
things that there's a finer line
you know but
people make bad decisions you know and
who views those like who am i to say
that decision is worth than a bad
decision i made in my life you know so
i've never looked at it like
personally like okay i'm going to lock
this guy up because he has the illegal
firearm okay he had an illegal gun he's
not trying to shoot me with it he might
fight over it maybe if he would have got
it he would have tried to shoot me but
it never happened so to me it's not a
personal
engagement it's a job you know a career
that i chose and i think a problem that
a lot of cops have
is they make it personal yep like oh
he's running for me nobody's running
from the police like it doesn't matter
who's wearing the badge he's running
from the bed you know what i mean right
and
in
in every aspect that's kind of where
i've just covered business you know like
you're still a person you know even if
you get into a scuffle with them they're
fighting and you're fighting and you're
trying to resist
you know detain them they're trying to
fight whatever happens in that moment
when it's done it's done right and but a
lot of people can't
separate this what do you think why is
that
ego
um
never being in that type of situation
never being punched in the mouth as a
kid i mean you know you have people that
come to this job and they've never been
in altercation and some people may say
well that's good i don't think it is
you know you come into an environment
like an inner city in in any state
and
you know you think
you're
an alpha male or you think you're a lion
and you're coming into an environment
with t-rexes you know what i mean people
that aren't scared of you you know
people that
don't fear you that aren't scared of
going to jail and you try to
act tough and trust me like people a lot
of cops
take for granted how smart the criminal
element is and i think
that's a big issue because they think
okay i'll just come here and
have my authority and i'll tell them
what to do when they're looking at my
dominance or something you know it's
when when you get resistance a lot of
people don't know how to handle that
because they've never had resistance in
their life you know and like i said
they've never been in a physical
altercation they've never been in an
uncomfortable situation
you know and i think
when people
find themselves in that situation fear
takes over absolutely and when fear
takes over bad decisions are made
absolutely you know and not saying that
there's malice behind it sometimes there
is
but a lot of times it's just few can you
give me an example of a time that you
that you feel like you've seen
you know someone on either side of the
law make a big mistake out of fear
oh yeah like
uh could not actually not long ago
chasing a dude he had a gun actually
maybe it was probably a month or two ago
maybe three
we're chasing a guy with a gun i i'm
chasing him i'm coming up behind him in
the car i jump out he tries to throw the
gun on the roof he doesn't realize it's
me
the gun doesn't make the roof falls back
down he goes to grab the gun and starts
like the turn like with me i think like
towards me what they're going like
getting the shootout probably yeah and
then looks up and sees me
and like oh [ __ ] madge and drops it
you know what i mean and he was about to
make a real bad decision yeah being that
i've been in a neighborhood pretty much
my whole life working i knew his dad you
know and um i think
even though it was a bad decision he
corrected it immediately i'm sorry so he
goes to grab the gun he turns to you
like he's about he's about to pick it up
yeah because you know he's
in his mind this is it right like i'm
this is my i'm shooting out that's it
so
when he he goes to grab and the gun is
like facing me so he goes to grab it as
he's going to grab he comes like he's
going to come up with it and i'm pulling
my gun out now because you know i'm
thinking okay this is going to be it
yeah and then he says oh [ __ ] man like
drops it he's seen you he knows you you
know his dad got you yep
it was a really bad decision regardless
now it was corrected quickly by him but
if it wasn't me who knows what happens
right right that's a bad decision i
don't think you know
i don't think he really wanted to do it
yep he just was so scared he didn't know
what else to do not saying that makes it
right right but that's just kind of like
fear can take your body over totally and
make you do something that you do not
want to do in both realms police and
criminal you know and and it happens on
both sides like you see a lot of these
police shootings throughout the country
and a lot of them could have been
avoided you know because you either see
the cops scared to put their hands on
somebody because they don't know how to
defend themselves or handle themselves
and then it escalates too quickly to a
firearm and now someone's shot you know
and a lot of times it may be a justified
shooting but i think with better
training it could have been avoided
altogether yeah you know and i think
that's that's where fear comes in to
play because it's a it's a very
controlling
um emotion you know what i mean like
we've all felt fear at some point in our
lives it's just how you deal with it
when was that like can you think of a
time that that that that you feel like
fear got the better of you
uh on the street
yeah i think i mean i physically like
um
never like physically as far as like i
was too aggressive i think
verbally i think there's been times
where um the situation at hand like
fighting over a gun and maybe the gun
was out and like you're fighting for the
gun and it's a pretty intense situation
and you end up winning but you're so mad
because you know how close you were to
losing your life right and like you
started to like god damn you started to
yell get aggressive i think because that
ain't you i've seen that i think in
moments like that i've lost my cool
verbally right and it's very rare
like
to me for me to lose my cool verbally
like that so i think
like reflecting on those moments it was
probably fear that
man this was about the end of it and it
was only after i had my son yeah like
after i had my my son i became a lot
more conscious of the things i did on
the street as far as the risk i took
because you you need to get home yeah
and i mean i i had somebody i was
responsible for now like before that i
mean i i really just
thought i was mel gibson lethal weapon
man like i just that's how i wanted to
be like just you know
doing the best job i could and being
wild and having the adrenaline pump
because that drowning is like a drug
you know when you when you're chasing
someone with a gun or you're chasing a
car
you're chasing a shooting suspect or a
murder suspect
that adrenaline that is pumping through
your body is like something you will
never feel anywhere else yeah you know
and i think
that's what you live for and before i
had my son
i didn't really care like what i was
doing like i didn't care who i was going
after or maybe how reckless i was being
going after him you know once i had my
son i really kind of chilled out a
little bit is there any way you could
count the amount of times that you've
had to engage in like physical
like in a fight on the street like that
involved a gun like it's more time like
yeah a lot i mean i've probably been
involved in a thousand handgun arrests
in my career and i mean if we had to
count the times we fought over them
i mean maybe 200. right you know i mean
i don't know i it's it's a lot more than
i'd want you know what i mean like knock
on wood you know you're
a lot of it's luck
that a bad thing didn't happen a lot of
is training too and training that i've
taken on myself to make sure that you
know i'm prepared while i'm out there
yeah and that's an issue that a lot of
cops don't train you've had fighting
experience you've trained jiu-jitsu you
train mma what percentage you think of
of cops out there have that level of
training or like have have taken upon
themselves to
three percent small five percent yeah a
little small you know and some may do it
for a short period of time i mean i
found i found myself doing that like rob
would train really hard and then i would
not train and then it would take a
situation on the street where i was i
mean i could have went really bad yeah i
need to get back in the gym and focus
and do you think that the training like
being proficient with your hands is
something you and i have talked about a
bunch like do you think that that helps
you
tactically or does it
or or psychologically or both and like
both both and can you tell me how yeah i
mean if
if you're comfortable
in a physical altercation like
obviously you don't know who you're
dealing with and anytime you
underestimate someone you you're gonna
you know you could possibly have already
lost so you have to be aware that
you know the person you're dealing with
might be
better than you and everything you're
good at
but if i think
as a for your own peace of mind if
you're trained and you feel like you're
pretty decent at certain things and you
can handle yourself you know how to
control the human body in certain cities
excuse me in certain situations you know
how to hold someone down you know how to
get someone's arms behind their back you
know
you you have more confidence and it's
less likely that you'll escalate your
force before it needs to be escalated
right and then you're controlling your
fear and the way that you're
communicating is from a place of sort of
i mean there's something i mean we've
all been in this situation you know
anybody who trains where you just
somebody's got the better of you and and
then it's easy you know if you're under
the umbrella of the safety of being in
an academy or you know you can box out
you can you can tap out you can take a
knee whatever but i think that that
actually actually to a certain extent i
would imagine exists on the streets too
like if you can control a situation you
don't
you don't need to go to a place that you
don't want to go yeah i mean you see it
when people
like if i'm fighting a guy over a gun
and like my guys are like trying to help
and i got the gun in my hand like he's
got the gun in his hand i'm like all
right guys you know trying to say just
grab him hold his arm hold his arm
you're super calm right
someone that's not confident in their
ability or confident that they know what
they're doing is going to be screaming
and you see it oh my god they're yelling
you know it's like it escalates everyone
yeah escalates all the cops it escalates
to citizens because it makes a situation
even though it's a really bad situation
but it makes it seem even worse because
this person's screaming now you know
they're yelling all this crazy stuff
because they're they're hysterical
because the fear is starting to take
over their body and now if that fear
continues to take over and nothing is
getting resolved you're still fighting
whether it's for like 30 seconds a
minute whatever
you begin to escalate your force yeah
you know and that's when bad things
start to really happen now sometimes you
know you have like a split second time
to make a decision and you just have to
live with it no matter which way you go
yeah and you know a lot of times you may
regret the decision you made but it may
have been the right decision but you
don't have a lot of time to decide but
in situations where you have the time
you know and
the reason your family is because you
haven't prepared yeah you know like look
no agency in this country that i know of
gives their people the time to prepare
you know they give you a little bit of
training a little bit of like remedial
and then you're on your way you know
what i mean like every year you get a
little bit of training and you go about
your business and you can blame the
departments all you want for that but
ultimately you have to make the decision
if this is your career this is your path
and you know you can lose your life any
day you go to work why wouldn't you take
the time
to train yourself to find someone who
can make you better right you know to
find someone that can
teach you things that will help you
survive so like when i hear people [ __ ]
the department doesn't give them
training like these agencies not get it
and it should be allowed you know we
should be allowed training time
but ultimately if you're not taking the
time for yourself to do it you're just
you know you're just bitching for no
reason
you know like you could take time out of
your day go spend an hour and train
somewhere and learn something yep you
know so and when and your your initial
decision to do this like to to to make
this your career how did you make that
decision was there one thing that kind
of spurned it on and how did what what
effect did that have on on your family
uh
i'm the only cop ever in my family that
i know of um not only anyone ever
thought i would be a cop growing up
uh just because this is not what we
would know what we did
and i mean my family was very proud you
know like
i made a decision to do something that
was out of the norm not that my family's
like a bunch of criminals you know what
i mean but we just grew up in a
neighborhood where there weren't cops
like in our family you know i mean or
even like that lived in our neighborhood
we just kind of you know
we just wasn't there yeah so i think
they just
they love the fact that i'm a cop and
they respect it and they know who i am
as a person and like my one brother he
works with a lot of guys and i've
arrested yep you know and i mean he's
he they talk about me all the time he
always tells me you know hey they ask
how you're doing whatever and things
like that and you know so i i just i
don't know like what moment in my life i
just think i'm going to be a cop
uh i think it was just kind of a build
up that
i just
thought you know i could maybe make a
difference you know and
you know the the
the excitement of it you know like i
thought that was pretty interesting you
know so and of all the jobs that you've
had as a as a police officer what what
job you feel like you've been able to
have the biggest effect like what job do
do you enjoy the most um what what what
has been sort of like
your favorite time as as a police
officer in your career
i mean doing what i do
i've pretty much done the same thing my
whole career you know i mean i came out
on patrol like everyone you ride around
you find your niche what you're good at
or you know and
or what you enjoy doing and for me it
was like targeting people with like gun
crimes drug crimes things like that
violent
repeat violent offenders
targeting people that were like persons
of interest like shootings and things
like that
i've always kind of been in that area of
police work
and for me it's like i've locked up a
lot of people in my career a lot of guys
that i've arrested you know did prison
time they've come out and i've
seen them on the street and we talked
i've had lunch with a bunch of them i
said my brother works with a bunch of
guys i put away and
one thing that this
there's a mutual respect you know and
even after like doing time and you know
and and i put them there and they can
still come up to me and talk to me and
thank me and say hey man like you know
you you were stand up and you know for
me that's
that that takes more on their part
than for me to be a cop and like take my
time to talk to them because they went
to prison like yeah they may have earned
it like they may have did the crime but
as a as a person you know they went to
jail yeah or they went to prison
whatever it may be and they were gone
let's say a year two five ten whatever
it is and for them to be man enough for
warning enough to come out and to be
able to like swallow their pride and
like thank you it was also i mean man it
says [ __ ] volumes about you and i've
seen it like i've seen how you are for
me i i really like that means a lot to
me [ __ ] yeah you know regardless of what
they did or
i'm like damn like you know and i see a
lot of cops don't like to enter engage
like that they don't like to engage with
people because they take it personal you
know they're like oh they're out here
doing this that dollar and they take it
personal and i just think if if they can
learn
to not take it so personal but do you
think that that like obviously you know
you come from you come from that air you
come from east baltimore you come from i
mean do you think it's possible to to to
to truly sort of have that like kind of
empathy and understanding if you've
never experienced it if you've never
kind of been on that side of things yeah
i mean when you see
um new cops come from areas that aren't
as impoverished as baltimore and don't
have that type of demographic you
definitely see a difference
in the person and i don't mean it like
that they're a mean person or they have
malice in their heart or anything
they're just not used to the environment
you know they don't understand how
people are living you know and uh that
with that being said it's not saying
that everyone i come in contact with is
a good person you know and they're doing
they and they're you know some people
are just evil you know but you have to
be able to recognize that you know and
you have to it's just like when people
are bashing the cops and cops are all
taking it personal because they're
bashing the cops you know they're
they're bashing the profession you know
you can't take it personally you know
yeah it sucks because this is what you
do
but
they don't know you do you think it's
dangerous do you think bashing the cops
is dangerous do you think it's a kid
yeah i think
i think it's definitely dangerous
because
it's it's the only profession that i
know of where
someone does something wrong and let's
say a cop commits a crime and takes
someone's life like murders them right
it's the whole profession suffers from
it you know and i get it's a heinous act
and it needs to be dealt with but it's
there's no other profession that i know
that's like that you look at any other
profession
where there's corruption
and it's it's dealt with in that part
like if this is the corrupt group that's
who we deal with it doesn't hinder the
entire profession right and you look at
anything in history whether it's doctors
the catholic church or whatever the case
may be it doesn't
affect that profession or that realm
like it does police so and and i
with that being said i i to a certain
point i understand it you know because
the power that we have you know we have
a lot of power and we can take people's
freedom and you know if it comes down to
it we can take their life if we have to
to save others
so that's a lot of power that you have
but ultimately you know the majority of
cops just want to do a good job no no
cop wants to kill like at least let me
say no i'm sure there's some [ __ ]
out there that are not good for this
profession but most of us don't ever
want to have to shoot anyone or kill
anyone right i mean we really don't like
i don't want that on my conscience you
know like even if i'm justified even if
i had to you don't know how that's going
to affect you you don't know how it's
going to affect their family you don't
want to have to be in that situation
right now unfortunately it happens you
know and but i just hope it never
happens you know and it happens
hopefully it can stop happening in the
volumes that it is but
you know again
no one person has the answer yeah and if
i come to you and i'm like this is how
we fix it yeah i'm just a fool yeah
no no one person knows how to fix it
yeah you know i mean they just don't
yeah explain just like a little bit
about just for people who don't don't
know
like what what is like
plain clothes flex unit sort of like
aggressive policing like what like how
would you explain it so how it used to
be it's a little different now years ago
um plain clothes units like you
basically just like this i mean you know
you had your badge around your neck you
had you know your fez doing your vest
one underneath your clothes you know you
had your gun and your radio and that's
pretty much what you did and
um depending on what unit you were in
um it could be target based where you
know you have a target and you need to
go like investigate that target it could
be where you just ride around and try to
like
um work the street in a street level
capacity where you're looking for things
on view and trying to prevent crime and
things like that it just depends on what
stage of that unit you're in um if
you're targeting guys you know you're
following them you're doing like covert
and watching them you're writing search
warrants you're doing things like that
trying to put a case on them because you
know if they're a violent repeat
offender you know
you want to target them so you don't
keep committing crime whether it be
shootings murders um you're selling
drugs you know heroin code things like
that uh robbery rape whoever whoever
you're given as the target you know i
mean normally there's a reason you're
given a target and would you say i mean
like i know like right now in this
country one of the big things that a lot
of people some some some people would
call them experts whatever would
attribute sort of like the raising
of like all the crime in big cities
right now the race especially violent
crimes because a lot of these sort of
like plainclothes units are being kind
of disbanded or at least their met their
sort of methodologies are being hindered
in a certain way
what do you think about that like do you
think that's right to a certain extent
or i think a misconception is that you
can't
be a good cop and an aggressive cop yeah
can you tell exactly i think that's a
huge misconception
um right now the big sound across this
country is community policing
and
they act like we haven't been doing it
you know any good cop
is part of that community you know
whether you come up and you're playing
catch with the kid or you're walking by
a cookout and talking to the citizens
it's something we've all done our entire
careers but there's across the nation
it's being sold like this is a new
you know air and we're doing community
policing and the misconception is you
can't be an aggressive cop and still
serve the community and be
community-minded right and it's it's sad
because it's not true
well i know it's not true because i've
seen you but i mean do you but like when
you talk about the less trained the more
fearful
like um because it seems to me that you
know if you're in one of those you know
if you're in one of those units it's
like part of your job is again it's like
for lack of a better word it's like
you're going out looking for it like
you're going out like looking for those
guys getting like that that
that is how crime rates get lower like
you're engaging taking more criminals
off the street but
also if you happen to be
a weaker cop a shittier cop a more
fearful cop you're in a greater position
you're going out looking for it so
you're you're also like violating people
you're you're in a situation where
you're violating people's rights more
often and you're causing strife or
potentially grief in that
you know in that community because
you're engaging people and sometimes
you're engaging people that don't need
you know sometimes you're wrong yeah so
there was a time where you know like the
zero tolerance error of policing across
the country where everyone's getting
locked up for petty crimes yeah and in
in my pers
from my view what happened there in
baltimore
was you had a lot of cops that weren't
arresting people before zero tolerance
and then decided that okay we can lock
people up now and they made it easy for
me because of these petty crimes they
didn't want to put the work in you know
to maybe investigate a burglary from the
street level like a patrol person or to
like
get in a covert and sit there for hours
and watch a drug dealer and lock them up
so yeah i definitely think that
you know you you had cops that were lazy
and they probably made a ton of mistakes
um doing things they probably shouldn't
have did i'm sure that happened all over
the country yeah because you know it was
even though
i've never i've never been told in my
career you need to go lock up max amount
of people or you need to go
write x amount tickets i've never been
told that but you know there was
definitely like an idea that you had to
lock people up
you know and
but for me that wasn't an issue because
like i would go get in covert i would go
do things and make a rest and like
if you don't know what you're doing
then like you're trying to make an
arrest and you're not educated on like
probable calls and you know you're not
educated on how to make the arrest
properly yeah yeah you could be
violating someone's rights i mean you
could be making an unlawful arrest yeah
and i'm sure it's happened yeah and i'm
sure people like i get people feel a
certain kind of way about that yeah but
that's
that's that's a problem you know yes and
it should be fixed but again it comes
down to
fear and not just fear of the criminal
but the fear of the repercussions that
if you're not viewed as a worker how you
be treated in the department
you know what i'm saying yeah like i
said i've never been told to go out and
do x y and z like as far as numbers
um i've never seen that done
but it like you have a job like you know
your job is to go out there and you know
enforce laws you know stop crime if you
can prevent violence prevent crimes help
the community and so you have it you
know you're basically given a set of
keys and a radio and you're going to go
do your job
now
no matter if this person is a lazy cop
they're probably lazy in every aspect of
their life
you know it just because they become a
cop doesn't all my automatically made
them a hard worker yeah we're a good
person you know or intelligent or any of
those things you know so if this person
was worthless before they got the badge
they're going to be worthless with the
badge you know i think a lot of that can
can be fixed in in in recruiting yeah
you know recruiting so many people slip
into cracks that shouldn't be cops yeah
can we see it how would you fix that
uh
i don't know if i have the answers but i
mean you could
have better people in recruitment
have better personable people and
recruitment that knew how to
interview someone like you would know
like you can sit down with somebody in
two seconds and be like all right like i
i get what kind of game why would you
want someone interviewing a potential
candidate to become a cop if they've
never done an interview in their career
or if they've never been on the street
that seems crazy to me like if i'm
interviewing you
right i'm i'm doing your
all your interviews to become account
trying to gauge who you are
and i've never done an interview in my
career with someone who is deceptive
yeah a criminal element like that's
smart and is trying to deceive you yeah
and you're trying to figure out
bullshitting you if they're being honest
or what the case may be you're trying to
build that rapport and you you build
you know um
an expertise in interviewing someone and
you look for things that stand out like
they're lying or they're being deceptive
and if you've never done that in your
entire career but now you're in
recruitment and trying to bring cops in
yeah and trying to weed out the bad ones
yeah you have no skill in doing it yeah
so i feel like that's an area that could
definitely be fixed everywhere yeah like
in every department yeah recruitment
could be
i feel like i've never been in
recruitment so i don't know how they're
trained i mean i could speculate across
the country how recruitment's trained
but i feel like you need
like they should be definitely skilled
and interview
someone and try to like you know
recognize deception and things like that
far from the lie detector like yeah
you're giving a lie detector test yeah
but other ways you know what i mean like
just talk to me a little bit about like
uh just something i'm really interested
in just like kind of loyalty no matter
what side of the law you're on there's a
lot of that and i think to a certain
extent it's absolutely necessary like
you got to be a certain guy you have to
be the kind of person who's there for
someone else in a pinch and i just was
wondering like if you could talk about
times where like someone's really gotten
your [ __ ] back and also when
someone's like really let you down and
then also have you seen any examples of
like loyalty on the other side of the
law where that you came away from really
respecting
yeah so for me i mean
you know like when you're in those
moments and you're like getting heated
and you're fighting with a guy or
the situation's out of control you know
and
when it becomes the kind of calm like
starts to calm down and you're still in
at that level where you're like i said
like the one time when i was yelling and
a couple times i lost my core and
screaming
and someone like that worked for me like
you know here there's an officer and i'm
a supervisor comes over and grabs you
i'm like sorry it's orange stop
you know
this is the officer the lawsuit may be
scared to do that you know because this
is the person that ranked like i really
don't want to get involved you know
because i don't want this guy to look at
me a certain kind of way but when you
have that relationship with people you
know when they see you're acting out of
character you know and you're about to
do something you might regret you
shouldn't do and they step in and grab
you and calm you down to me it shows how
loyal they are because they're willing
to risk maybe how i'll act
react to them like in that moment right
like to help me you know and vice versa
like when you see someone maybe about to
step over that line like if they're
getting a fight with a guy and you're
pulling up on it it looks like it's
getting carried away you know you run
over and pull them off of them and grab
them and calm it down
you know it
it shows a lot like you're looking out
for both the interest of both you don't
want more force to be used and what
should be used right and you don't want
to come to make a mistake because he
couldn't just be in the heat of the
moment so i mean you look at the george
floyd situation you see those cops sort
of like standing there without going
down like she's like what's your t i
mean even though that that guy had rank
he had years they were new i mean what
like how do you explain there's no need
to nail on someone like that for
12 minutes 13 minutes whatever it was it
gets
look i don't know what that dude's
intentions were like i'm but regardless
of what it was going through his mind
there was just no need if you stand up
and that's it roll him over and it's
done like it was just
maybe he was trying to be a dick and he
hadn't caused some man is like he's
gonna go to prison for it but those
maybe those other guys
all the other guys they were scared
that's fear yeah that's fear of like i'm
going to step in on a senior officer and
he maybe that that guy is probably a
dick and you know like
young officers that made him feel like
[ __ ] or whatever and they were the same
[ __ ] if you act like that there you are
exactly so they were probably scared to
step in
because they didn't know what to do
they're probably
look if you're not a confident person in
in anything you do like like i said it's
going to turn out bad in their
situations because you're not going to
intervene when you should yeah you know
and and who's who knows what would
happen if they pull them off that maybe
that never happens and we're not in that
situation you know but
like i said that dude probably was that
type of cop and they were scared to say
anything to him and ultimately it calls
that man his life and he's going to go
to prison for it and what about the
other side of loyalty what about the
side where you you actually were in
danger and somebody was there for you
no i mean that's that means the world
you can't
look someone's in them fights with you
chasing the guy with a gun you know and
there's you know um you pull up on it on
a shootout or discharge you're chasing
dudes but to just fire guns off of
trying to kill people and you got
somebody right next to you running with
you that says a lot i mean you can't
you know it's i've never been in the
military or anything but i'm sure it's
similar to a lower scale on our side of
how that makes you feel you know what i
mean that they're willing
to risk their life side by side with you
and not let you run in that alley by
yourself or and sometimes there's a bond
there that yeah you'll never break that
bond i mean it doesn't mean that they
can't do any wrong
it just means that you're really going
to try to look out for them the best you
can and make sure they're on the right
track and vice versa you know what i
mean
but yeah i mean you you build bonds in
this job the camaraderie is big
i didn't come in here looking for a
reputation you know what i mean i didn't
come in here thinking i want to be
viewed like this type of cop or person
i came in here just to do a good job and
you know i kind of police the way i
thought you should police you know i
treated people the way they thought and
i thought they should be treated and i
think over the years on the street and
in the department with the with the
lower rank you know i've built a certain
reputation and not that i've looked to
do it it's just kind of where it fell
you know and i think if you treat people
right
whether they work for you they work
around you or you're policing them
they'll treat you right now look there's
exceptions to every rule you know and
you're going to have those douchebags
and [ __ ] in the department and on
the street then no matter how well you
treat them they just don't care right
you know but overall you can't gauge how
you treat people
by the few that don't you know
the few that don't respect it yeah you
know so yeah and right now like what
what's the in your opinion what's the
state of
policing in baltimore like what what is
you know like what is what do you where
do you think we're at i don't think
people like i don't think a lot of cops
are bought into it anymore you know it's
look i love the job and when i'm on the
street i'll do the job the best i can
and you know like i said because the
adrenaline's going and you know you're
there the problem is a lot of cops
it's hard when you feel like no one has
your back and you're going out there and
risking your life to do certain things
you might not go that extra mile now you
might not
look as hard as you should for something
going wrong in the neighborhood you know
what i mean and i'm sure a lot of that
how do you feel like no one has your
back right now specifically it's hard
man it's hard to explain because
you just feel like
you're out there on your own and if
something pops off
you're going to be guilty until you're
proven innocent right or until you're
cleared and no one's going to speak out
for him be like look they had to do what
he had to do
we'll investigate it you know but let
the facts come out until we judge them
you know and and if it's wrong it's
wrong if it's right it's right but you
you kind of feel like you're out on an
island right now you know and you're
just not
like they keep changing legislation and
like taking away like rights as far as
like when we get charged with crimes and
things like that and look man i'll be
the first to tell you if a cop is doing
something like that they get what they
deserve they're selling drugs and
stealing money and playing evidence and
all that [ __ ] whatever comes their way
is what they deserve yeah you know
but the issue is you
it's
it's affecting everyone and i
i get depressed i get it you know i
understand why it's why it's on
everyone's mind because there's been a
lot of egregious incidents over the last
few years you know especially with like
the george ford incident and you know
but
you
you there has to be a fun it has to be a
medium position it can't be all or
nothing yeah you know what i mean like
yeah you want to weed out the bad cops
but
the perception is that the bad cops are
doing everything around the good cops
and that's just not true yeah you know
if you if if you have friends that are
involved in illegal [ __ ] that they know
you ain't down with they ain't gonna do
it around you right yeah you said
there's like there there's absolute evil
out there
you you feel like you've you've
encountered evil oh yeah i've seen evil
man and like like can you give me
exactly your words like what evil was
yeah like you know when i seen it more
in patrol when i first came out because
like being in my field you're only going
after a certain group of individuals
that are involved in like guns and drugs
and things like that but in patrol man
your call could be anything
you go to like like
in my district you had johns hopkins
so you know you you respond to the
hospital whether it's for like a child
abuse or rape things like that you know
and for me it's it's kids man like you
see a kid
you know beat the pulp you know we're
killed you see a kid shot
you know or um
a kid beat to death or
boiling water thrown on a kid something
like that man like that's just pure evil
man like you know
the the the gun violence when it's like
two groups battling
it sucks lives are being lost but it's
kind of like both groups know what
they're getting into and they're
battling it out and not saying it's
right but there's an understanding there
in that element of what they're into
signed up for what a kid man like you
know were innocent like an elderly
person or a woman to being raped or
brutalized they didn't sign up for that
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying like you
going bearing that kid you know with
beat the [ __ ] and you know you can't
even see their eyes because they're so
swollen or they're all cut off or
they're burned yeah you know that's uh
for me when i was like a new cop that
was one thing where i knew i just didn't
want to like be involved in yeah because
like i didn't know how how i would deal
with that situation yeah you know and
like i was scared of how i would react
yeah if i walked into that if i
continuously had like type of call and
i'd walk in like a guy like a father a
mother beat their kid like that or kill
their kid i'm not sure how i would react
you know what i mean like i knew that
yeah so i kind of like i knew that
wasn't my
you know area that i wanted to focus on
right like child abuse or
sex crimes because like i just didn't
know how i could handle it the
anti-police charge like where do you
think i mean obviously look man there's
all this [ __ ] in the news and all this
you know there's there's
issues of corruptions and these these
unjustified shootings [ __ ] like that but
like this idea of of kind of like police
reform and defunding the police and all
that like where do you think that stuff
is coming from
i mean i know we talked about this
before but like i just think this is
like i told you before like this is our
60s and 70s
you know this is our air for that you
know what i mean like we're living
through the 60s and 70s right now
whenever riots there was like you know
the vietnam you know um protests and
screw the police type by no idea what's
going on that's what we're living
through now look i think
that there was an idea
that there needs to be some reform in
certain styles of policing and i get and
i think it just snowballed into
something that it wasn't meant to be do
you think that there needs to be reform
in certain sides of policing i think
there needs to be reform in
training
and
and recruitment i think recruitment is a
big thing look man
you're always going to have corrupt
police because there's a human element
and in any profession there's always
going to be bad people yeah and police
work is no different yeah there's going
to be people to get through the cracks
yeah and they're going to do bad [ __ ]
it's going to happen it is never
not going to happen yeah and you uh you
love baltimore i do yeah we grew up here
and
it's it's going like this is a great
city man it's just going through a hard
time and
there's great parts of this city you
know it's it's a little gem you know
what i mean and but it has a bad rap
right now i mean
rightfully so i mean it's violent as
hell right now and
you know i mean violence in the country
it goes in laws you know what i mean but
you know he's really bad right now you
know i mean i don't really know what the
fix is yeah i think police work has come
has become too soft you know overall
um cops aren't as aggressive because
they're scared to get in trouble they're
scared that you know we feel like we're
dinosaurs you know we feel like
agencies
in this country don't want cops like me
anymore they don't want that aggressive
cop you know like i said it's a
misconception that you can't be a good
cop in an aggressive cup yeah and i
think that idea needs to change or this
is just going to continue yeah you know
like i don't have the single answer but
i think you know
recruiting better
allowing police to be police is probably
a good idea
you know obviously hold them you know
accountable
but look we have body cameras now we
have i've been working with a body
camera for years still being the same
cop i was
15 years ago and
i'm fine i i love my body camera yeah no
issues with it at all why do you love it
because it shows like it's it
it shows what you really do it shows
like when people say things you do and
you really don't do them and that camera
clears you like that to what extent do
you think that there's like real
currency of of of having a reputation as
a police officer as somebody who if if
you want to go there he will go there or
she will go there and also on the other
side like i i've also seen you know you
know guys on the streets guys who are
kind of career criminals and like you
guys have a mutual respect for each
other and how much of that is that
currency of violence it's it's huge i
mean it plays a big part and
right now the turnover rate is so high
most departments that it's hard to build
that type of poor reputation
with with people which is another big
thing like you got to learn how to
retain police or else you can't have
community policing if no one ever builds
a report with people in the community
right and the door is revolving so fast
now that there's not enough time for a
lot of these officers to build reports
right so like in
me coming up like yeah cops have
reputations like you know even when you
just pull onto the street and they see
you
everybody knows your lifestyle changes
right like you know they're like oh [ __ ]
he's out be careful don't be stupid yeah
you know you have nicknames they give
you nicknames or whatever and you build
a rapport and look if you're a [ __ ] cop
they're going to know it they're going
to call you out everyone's going to know
because the bird's going to get out yeah
if you're good at your job if you're
like
respectful if you you know please write
that word gets out too and people
respect you and vice versa yeah and
again it just comes down to having a
mutual respect yeah you know
understanding that it's not personal
yeah you know they're not out there
doing this despite
anthony maggio right you know they're
out there
selling drugs or doing whatever they're
doing because that's just what they
chose to do yeah has nothing to do with
them many of you make it personal you've
lost yeah you know and you're going to
lose yourself in that moment yeah so i i
just think if you if you're out there
like if
if it gets if it gets aggressive and you
have to fight and they see you can
handle yourself
there's a lot less chance that someone
will try you that's it huge huge like if
you get out there and a dude works you
up and he takes all like he throws you
down and runs away from you every person
you try to lock up is going to throw you
down and try to run away from it that's
right because they know they can do it
but if they try that and you dump them
or slam them or you know if they throw a
punch and you you know your punch is
faster whatever the case may be and they
really ain't one to mess with yeah they
just don't do it yeah you know and look
you have the ones that will test you and
there's always a exception to them rules
but
yeah reputation is huge on both sides
yeah you know like you know that there's
some guys that you just can't calm down
right like if so-and-so comes up and
starts running his mouth the best thing
to do is ignore him because no matter
what you say to him you're never going
to calm that dude down right because
he's just being in there but that but
that is community but that is like
having an intimate not like
understanding who's who and who does
what and like hey look that's why this
whole thing with like
trying to sell the community policing
model all across the country
you need retention to sell that model
because if you're not retaining cops and
if these cops aren't in these
neighborhoods longer than six months a
year they're not building rapports with
the community you know neither they're
chasing call to call
where they have time to build a rapport
and then they quit go to another agency
go to another line of work and you have
a whole new set of cops that come in and
try to do it yeah so you're never
building that rapport yeah where like
i've worked in that same neighborhood
pretty much most of my career yeah you
know and i've been dealing with a lot of
these guys since they were kids and you
grew up there right and like the first
guy i locked up i grew it wow you know
like d when i met d we had a mutual
friend yeah that we knew growing up you
know and it's like that dude poured a
gun on me
so it's like yeah that helps yeah but
even when i went to like the west side
for a little bit it's the same thing
yeah if you just treat people
a certain kind of way it will repay
itself yeah you know and not that you're
looking for repayment
but it's just karma yeah you know it's
just you treat people right like i told
you a story when i got my car stuck in
the mud when i was young cop no
so there was a dude he was a big time
drug dealer and uh i was young men
patrol had like six months on you know a
hard charge and whatever and i used to
always like try to get this guy and
i was brand new had no idea what the
hell i was doing always making mistakes
you know trying to get in the coat like
a vacant house and watching making too
much noise you know whatever the case
may be just always screwing it up yeah
and uh
one day i'm like i'm gonna get this dude
grandma get his ass today came out early
in my car and i went through the alley
and i was trying to park my car like
like two alleys down the street got born
and i got stuck in the mud
and i'm back my wheels are spinning you
know i'm rubbing an engine i can't get
out man and he this was a big dude he
was a he's a i'm not gonna put his name
under because i know i don't want to
throw him out there like that but he was
a big guy about
six six three fifty yeah and his bro and
his buddies and brothers were the same
size yeah and so as i'm back there
trying to get my car out of this mud and
the wheels are spinning you know i'm
like oh man this sucks
him and his two buddies come walking
into the alley and they're huge i mean
he's a big ass dude yeah and i'm like
damn i get out of my car man what's up
man he's like what are you doing oh yeah
i got my car stuck
and he was like he's trying to watch me
weren't you
i was like yeah i was trying but i
[ __ ] that you know what i mean he's
like ah man we got you and they pushed
me those three big ass dudes pushed me
out of mud wow and
you know
like at the moment you really don't
realize what it is but as you get older
because i mean i was 21 young you know
you just realize what that meant [ __ ]
you here i am trying to put these dudes
in jail and they realize i don't know
what the hell i'm doing cause i'm brand
new and you know
they went over there and pushed me out
you know and
that just
it shows
a mutual respect that's it you know and
even like i got in a fight one time
locking a dude up on mine the street and
then my gun flew out of my holster
i mean flew out of it like me and this
guy are going at it and as we're
fighting like he somehow
hit my gun and it flew out of the
holster and slid down the street and
this dude and i'm not going to say his
name
he walks over
and stands over top my gun and wanted no
one touching until i got to doing
handcuffs i walked over he was like here
you go man and i was like thanks you
know and you you those moments here's a
guy who's been to prison you know i put
him in prison before and wow you know
stood there and so why did he do that
just because he he said i always treated
him right
you know like guys that work with my
brother they just always say and i'm a
stand-up dude and again
i don't think it should be a mindset
where you go out there and you're like i
need to be a stand-up dude you know what
i mean like you shouldn't have to think
about it you know you have these classes
where they're telling you how to talk to
people like you shouldn't have that like
you failed already yeah you're gonna do
that that way you are right like you
you've either been brought up that way
you have that mindset or you don't
i don't go out there and like
consciously say okay i need to be a good
person today you know what i mean i need
to not
violate someone's rights today like you
just shouldn't be thinking like that it
should just be natural you got to do the
right thing right you know and that's
why like
i think it just falls back to recruiting
the right people you're doing a better
recruitment process of getting the right
people in here yeah but i think honor is
exactly like what you were talking about
as well being open-minded being able to
like sit down with somebody who thinks
differently than you and being confident
enough in your opinion that you're not
going to be shook if you meet somebody
from a different area or different
different sexual orientation different
religion different like whatever man and
uh you know like right now it's like
having the loudest voice being like it's
my way or the [ __ ] highway and i
personally i think that's pretty soft
you know you know like uh you know you
know rigidity and and and um being uh
unwilling to deal with anybody different
just you know it reeks of fear to me you
know what i'm saying yeah i mean if
again it's
it's a it's a mechanism where people
aren't confident
that they want to be their own voice
heard
you know and that's their
defense to not being secure in who they
are
i think
like my son asked me because like he
always asked me stories about being
police and
like uh he asked me how i changed you
know like when because i told him when i
had him i i stopped being as crazy like
you know as aggressive and reckless as i
was and
you know i thought about it for a long
time because i've already know how to
answer it you know and and for me change
has always been a scary word you know i
think for a lot of people it is [ __ ]
like even like in police work right now
like a lot of cops are trying to change
the way i police
and
kind of like i don't think change ever i
don't think it's ever changed man like
i don't think society anyone allows
anyone to truly change
we all adjust
like
when i retire no matter what i go to do
i want to be the former cop i can't ever
change that i can adjust my lifestyle
just who i am i can adjust my brain if
if i was addicted to something and now
no longer am i addicted to it and i kind
of got this perspective like talking to
guys that got off drugs and you know
they're like man i'm always gonna be an
addict i just gotta live today for today
and you know like they take it day to
day yeah and they like
they never change who they are like it's
not change they're just adjusting their
life and i think if we can start
kind of
stop like saying we're gonna change you
we're gonna change the way you do this
and we're going to adjust it yeah people
will receive it a lot more yeah like if
you try to change someone they take that
immediately as the [ __ ] you trying to
change me for yeah you know saying like
you're trying to change me yeah or are
you trying to change the way i do this
tell me i'm doing something wrong but if
i go to him like hey man let's adjust
the way we're doing some things yeah you
know what i mean
it i think in your mind get better man
right your mind that's it
interprets that a lot differently yeah
where it's not an aggressive thing yeah
like yeah i can adjust my lifestyle yeah
like in in in every aspect of life i
just don't think
change is what really happens yeah i
think it's just adjustments yeah because
we are who we are yeah like we can say
we're not going to be aggressive dudes
but that situation of rise
us and we have to we're going to be that
dude yeah you know we're going to have
to adjust back to who that person is in
police work because like you said
there's a big revolving thing going on
right now of changing the way police is
i think if we go about it and say hey
we're going to adjust the way we do
things it would be received a lot more
in agencies across the country and not
so much frowned upon like oh they're
trying to change the way we do our job
is not working yeah you know but we need
to adjust the way we're doing our job
because we can do better we can do
better yeah
i think in every aspect of life you can
you can use that admitting your mistakes
and and and acknowledging mistakes and
working on your mistakes it's like it's
like growing and like being a part of
something you're just trying to get
better and better and when i think about
like the state of policing in this
country and like where it is it's that
like the few guys that i've met i met a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of cops but i look at
these like choice few that i like look
at that way every single one is sort of
saying the same thing they're like i you
know i love the love the guys like i
know how i want to police i love what i
do i love the community i please i love
being there but i don't know how much
longer i can i can do it and and uh you
know that's that's uh
that that that's worrisome to me you
know yeah i mean it's it's tough when
like you gotta weigh like risk and
reward man like no one takes his job for
money no one takes his job for a pat on
the back at least they shouldn't i'm
sure there probably are maybe some
people that just need a job and they got
through the process but um yeah i mean
you take it for because you truly want
to help people you know and when you
feel like you can't do that anymore not
because you don't want to
but just because you're being hindered
you know because you don't have the
tools or you don't
you know you're not
you're kind of being reined in
it's it's tough it's tough to go out
there and like
risk it all knowing what you have to
lose
and
you know not knowing if
you know anyone's going to ever like
stick up for you yeah i think it'll turn
you know like it it's just going to take
some time you know like there's no one
person
that
is going to turn it you know i think we
can all be in agreement we don't need
backups you know but again if you're a
realist and you're open-minded you
realize they're always going to be there
you know it's just nothing you can do
about it you have to be humble and
you're never going to get better if
you're always the best guy in the room
that's right
and if you have that mindset if you feel
you're the best and you're not open to
getting better you're never going to get
better that's right and you're nowhere
near as good as you think you want right
in anything in any field you're in
i mean i just think
you always have room to grow you know
and i just that's
just kind of the mindset i've always had
you know i can always get better yeah
you know yeah
whether i achieve it or not i don't know
yeah
well that's that's the view
man i uh i really appreciate this man i
love that yeah it's [ __ ] great thank
you bro thank you ross
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff and mean a lot to us i
hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself